This video is made possible by Nord VPN. If you're online,
you really must be using a VPN. And that's where naughty VPN comes in.
I know it's tempting not to bother and hope for the best,
but really those stories you read about people having their data stolen do
happen. And you don't want to make it easy for anyone to do that.
But using a VPN offers more than just security. For example,
Nord VPN lets you access any of its thousands of servers in different countries,
all around the globe. So if you've hit the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server and get access to content
libraries that due to licensing agreements are only available in specific
geographic locations. For example,
most European countries have strong licensing agreements restricting which
soccer matches can be viewed depending on the location of the viewer with a Nord
VPN, you can change your country without even moving from your sofa.
No VPN is super fast. So watching a video is a breeze,
no lag whatsoever. If you've ever used a VPN and thought they were slow, well,
no more with Nord VPN and you can use it on all of your devices. Very,
very easily Android Chrome windows, Linux,
and on up to six different devices.
One account also there are no logs kept at hall.
Unlike companies based in the EU or U S North VPN is based in Panama.
So they don't have to keep logs at all. Great for your privacy.
So take control of your internet experience right now with Nord VPN and listen
up because they have a special holiday bill for a limited time.
Every purchase of a two-year plan saves you 68%.
Plus you'll get four additional mumps for free go to Nord,
vpn.com/visual politic or use code visual politic at checkout it's
risk-free with nods 30 day money back guarantee. And now let's get it.
[Inaudible].
When we think of Germany and try to do a mind map of what this country is like
and how it works. Most of us probably think of a very cohesive territory,
a country where the economy is doing well and where prosperity reaches
practically every corner, a real superpower in short, the powerhouse of Europe,
a country whose problem seems small compared to those we can find in other parts
of the old continent. Well,
friends hope that fault because the truth is that this is not the real story or
rather Germany is not exactly like that. At least not completely. You see,
although the division of Germany into two parts,
a capitalist West and a communist East formally ended on the 3rd of October,
1990, following the fall of the wall in November, 1989,
the country is still somewhat divided. Believe it or not,
we can still observe the existence of two great blocks. Yes, that's right.
We have not gone mad.
You could say that there is an invisible wall that divides two quite different
Germany's in this video, we're going to give you all the details. Friends,
the former territories of the German democratic Republic presents some
surprising and profound differences to those of the former federal Republic of
Germany that even today,
30 years after reunification have not been completely sorted out.
[Inaudible].
Let's start the story from the very beginning,
after being politically divided since 1945,
the communist government of East Germany closed the borders with the West in
1952,
the only exception that allowed relative freedom in moving from East to West was
Berlin. However, some years later in 1961,
the communist government of the GDR,
the German democratic Republic in view of a high number of defections that were
occurring, built the infamous Berlin wall since then,
the historic capital of the German empire became the living representation of a
division that conditioned politics of the whole world for decades,
East versus West capitalism versus communism,
NATO versus the Warsaw pact.
And not only that that's physical border then extended throughout Germany in
some areas in the form of a wall and in others of fences,
surrounded with watchtowers and armed soldiers.
And it was no bluff because the soldiers deployed on the border had a clear
order shoots to kill anyone who tried to escape in some places.
The separation consisted of double Gates with central areas full of concertina
wire. In fact,
almost one and a half million anti-personnel mines were laid along the border.
We're talking about a division,
a mutual isolation that contributed to creating an economic political and above
all a social wound, a wound that would Mark the future right up to them.
Today.
Think about it for a moment overnight 44,000 soldiers from the German democratic
Republic were given the mission of keeping the German people apart.
Their motto was to avoid any contact between the two sides.
Evidently since then, even beyond the ideological question,
the puffs that both countries followed in all orders were very,
very different over time.
The existence of these two Germany's generated important differences,
not only in terms of economic development levels, but also in social terms,
friends in this video,
we're going to try and look at the differences that even today,
30 years after reunification are still visible and that continue to condition
the political, social and economic reality of the new unified Germany.
Unfinished reunification.
No secret just as destroying is much easier than building.
So is separating much easier than putting back together in the case of Germany,
which is the subject of this video,
the differences and peculiarities between both parts of the formerly divided
Germany remained to this day. And even beyond the economy,
perhaps the most difficult thing to equalize and integrate is precisely their
different societies
In social and political terms.
There are important differences between the two former German republics.
And although it may seem surprising,
there is even mistrust and suspicion between East and West Germany, for example,
many Germans from the former few underrepresented in political and judicial
institutions and positions, fuss,
fueling a certain feeling of inequality to give you an example,
eight out of 10 judges and prosecutors in the East grew up in the West and no
major listed company in the country is based in the East, outside Berlin,
nor are there any of the large research development and innovation centers that
underpinned the competitiveness of large tonic companies located in this part of
the country.
There are even clearly marked political boundaries. In fact,
using the election results of the right-wing populist party alternative for
Germany and to the socialist de-linking, which translates as the left.
We could almost perfectly draw the border between these two.
And not only that, if we look concretely at the city of Berlin,
you can see that the areas where these two parties reap the most support
correspond exactly to what was once East Berlin,
the side that was under communist control. And the obvious question is why,
what explains such a difference?
What is behind these differences that even determined voting preferences?
Well friends, the truth is that in general,
Germans from these two sides still maintain different ways of seeing society and
understanding concrete aspect of politics. An example, well,
without digging too deep, let's take immigration and that is look closely at it.
The success of alternative for Germany in the East has a lot to do with the
rejection of Angela Merkel's refugee policies,
which have seen the country open its doors to nearly a million people since
2015.
And it makes sense after all East Germany has never traditionally been a place
of immigration.
So many East Germans view this influx with suspicion and distrust,
that is you may be more or less in favor of this type of policy,
but when you have not had any previous experience,
the fear rejection suspicion is usually much.
Great, sir.
But in the East, unemployment is somewhat higher and the wages are lower.
So that anti-immigration,
and even anti-European discourse has a better breeding ground.
The vast majority of Germans consider their lives to have improved since
reunification.
It is precisely the East Germans who consider themselves to have benefited the
most. I'm sure this is something that doesn't surprise you in the least.
In fact,
East Germans who currently rate their quality of life seven or higher have could
report between 1991 and 2019 reaching 59% of the total
group.
But hold on a moment just because things have improved does not mean that the
differences have completely disappeared.
German cohesion is not coming as quickly as was fought.
And now it is clear that the 20 year period that was initially estimated for
handling this was far too short. Of course, at this point,
I'm sure many of you were thinking, but Josh,
what exactly are these economic differences that are hidden behind this kind of
invisible wall and how do they stay hidden? Well, let's take a look.
One Germany, two speeds, friends.
It's a cool field is not the only area where we can find a Bismal differences
between the two Germany's. The economy also shows a similar phenomenon,
obviously moving overnight from a socialist economy where everything belongs to
the state and there is no private property to the capitalist.
One is not always easy or rather it is not always so easy to close the gap and
even more so when one of the sides was three or four times poorer than the other
after reunification, less than 10% of Eastern businesses operated at a profit,
most of the new companies were not up to the standards of the Western market.
DIW German Institute for economic reasons. Note that in 1991,
East Germany had a GDP per capita, three times lower than the West.
And its citizens had an annual gross income, 50% below that,
of their Western compatriots.
And although those differences have since narrowed substantially 30 years on
full alignment has still not been yet.
The chief.
The GDP per capita in the East is still 30% lower than in the West annual
household. Incomes are almost 20% lower. A difference that is even greater.
If we exclude the public sector, in addition,
unemployment is higher and the Eastern Landers income is no more than
60% of the federal average.
What's more an adult in the West has an average net worth of 120,000 euros,
which is more than double the average of 55,000 euros in the East of Germany.
In addition,
the reversal of the population pyramid is much more pronounced because many
young people have moved West the flow of investment and capital into the former
German democratic Republic was immense, but people went in the other direction,
the children who should have been born there are not there. Christina Von duvet,
DIW economist. You see, no matter how you look at it, there are differences.
And surprisingly,
there are some very particular things in the East as are actually better than in
the West. For example, the infrastructure. Yes, that's right.
I have not mixed these two things up. It's better in the East.
You see when the two sides were first reunited,
the socialist zone of the GDR had a huge lack of modern freeways.
The railroads were basically obsolete and basically all the transport networks
were defeated
Mostly because of this.
And to change this outlook West Germany embarked on a multi-million dollar
investment program in the East paid for by the taxes of the Germans of the
former federal Republic of Germany. And also with European funds,
the result was the building and reconstruction of 2000 kilometers of new main
roads.
And they completely renovated railroad network for which some 30 billion euros
was invested. The checkbook, the German politicians pulled out.
[Inaudible].
Of course, such an act of generosity was not without controversy.
As all these investments were made. The former West Germany,
the epicenter of Teutonic competitiveness and wealth fell behind to the point
where it had worse infrastructure,
especially railroads than in the East of the country where brand new ones had
just been built. In fact, if you travel through Eastern Germany,
you will see for yourself how many train stations are much more modern than
those in the West.
While the road infrastructure is also better planned and organized as well as
being in better shape. This is something that by the way,
causes resentment amongst Western Germans,
who are after all the ones who paid for it all,
but why undertake such a large investment in infrastructure?
See.
Fundamental idea in addition to uniting the territory was to facilitate the
industrialization of the former communist Republic and thus reduce the
differences between the two sites in economic terms, production and wages,
something that has more or less been achieved. Okay. Not quite,
but at least it's something on the other hand,
the main problem just before reunification was what to do with the huge
practically inoperative and very unproductive public enterprises in the GDR
here,
the only solution was to initiate a process of privatization that was by no
means an easy task.
And that had been ordered by the government of the GDR just before its
extinction through the so-called Troy [inaudible] or trust agency
Agency was a body created in 1990 by the East German council of ministers and
was operational until 1994.
Its aim and function was to privatize or sell the more than 8,000 public
enterprises of socialist Germany,
which employed almost 4 million people at the time.
The challenge they faced was the difficulty in placing all these companies and
their assets in the market. Why?
Because these massive and inefficient organizations were mostly oriented to
trade with the communist block.
And many of their factories also had obsolete machinery that did not meet
Western standards. And of course,
as the communist block was in a state of full collapse,
the turnover of these companies plummeted to such an extent that they were
plunged into a deep crisis at which point, the idea of ever becoming profitable,
again seemed a Miraj. Therefore,
one of the solutions they came up with was to divide some companies into smaller
entities to facilitate the access of small investors in the privatization
process.
That was not the only thing the trust agency did to prepare the country for
total annexation,
about 2.5 million hectares or almost 6.2 million acres of
agricultural land for privatized properties of the ministry of state security
were sold as well as army property and assets of the official political parties.
In any case, despite the problems,
the result was that many West German companies ended up buying all or parts of
East German companies who've established branches or production sites,
their first take advantage of lower wage costs.
And this was good.
In the sense that a lot of jobs were preserved and production was secured.
The only drawback for the future was that these regions subsequently specialized
in the lover value, added production and assembly phases. In other words,
the most qualified workers who research,
invent and create value stayed in the West whilst just some of those factories
of those products were moved to the East to further illustrate this in 2016,
400,000 from the East migrated to the West,
while only 150,000 Germans from the West migrated to the East.
This is something that over time has perpetuated the differences in income and
wages between Germans in the East and West of the country.
And obviously also the GDP of the new and old Landers in any case.
It also must be said that the progress that has been made is remarkable.
Of course now,
as you can imagine to balance the country as poor as the GDR with an industrial
and economic power,
like the FRG was far from cheap infrastructure levels of wellbeing,
reconstruction of the productive fabric remodeling of the cities, et cetera,
et cetera. So the question that comes up is,
but really how much has this whole process cost? Do you want to know the answer?
Well.
The price of division friends.
No mistake, the German reunification has been and remains a very,
very expensive experiment. Hold onto your chair.
According to estimates by the whole Institute for economic research between 1990
and 2009 alone,
the former capitalist FRG spent more than 1.3 trillion euros trillion
to subsidize the economic and social convergence of the former GDR.
To give you an idea,
this is almost double the entire recovery fund approved by the European
commission to deal with the coronavirus crisis. And that's not the end of it.
It is estimated that billions still flow from the West every year, every year.
Now, what has all this money been spent on?
And how has all this spending been financed? Well,
here comes another somewhat controversial story because much of that money was
spent for very different purposes than originally intended something that those
in the West did not find very funny. I'm basically referring to social service.
[Inaudible].
Although the initial investment was aimed at improving the competitiveness of
the East. For example, by promoting the modernization of companies,
it has been calculated that a large part of the funds have gone to other
purposes, such as social benefits, retirement, pensions, subsidies,
and aid of all claims in short, a lot of handouts were given to the citizens.
This is a handy carrot for any politician who aspires to win votes,
but in practice,
it does not create any productive structure that will serve to improve
sustainability, autonomy and living conditions in the future.
And of course,
those in the West of Germany began to complain and rightly so that their
compatriots in the East were becoming dependent on these handouts at the expense
of companies and taxpayers in the West sanctions were even demanded for Eastern
Landers who did not spend the money properly. This was never enforced.
The point is that they have many reasons to be angry because a good part of the
money that Eastern Germany has received since 1995 has been financed by a
solidarity tax or rather a surcharge popularly known as the soul.
Well, this surcharge,
the Sali has collected 331 billion euros since its creation in
1995,
through a 5.5% surcharge added to or income tax capital gains tax
and corporate tax payments above a certain income threshold.
According to the calculations of the Frankfurter,
Allgemeine those items without this tax,
the average income would save about 900 yeah.
Euros a year.
Something that those in the West will experience soon as it is a tax that will
disappear in 2020.
German government moves to end solidarity tax for Eastern Germany.
So there you have it. German reunification has cost a lot of money.
Yet there are still important economic,
political and social differences today that invisible wall that separates the
East from the West still seems very much in place.
And you can also see how it is much easier to divide them put back together.
But having said that, it's your turn.
Do you think that both parts of Germany will be completely homogenous one day,
leave us your answers here below in the comments. And if you liked this video,
don't forget to hit like and subscribe to our channel.
So you don't miss anything new that's coming up, take care until next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media. We have a
podcast@reconsideredmedia.com slash podcast. See you then.